[Music]
we are very excited to reboot our chef
in a shoestring segment this morning
with a new food segment simply called
the dish
instead of three recipes
that was a clip from exactly one decade
ago that's right this morning is the
10th anniversary of the dish and to mark
the occasion we have a very special one
for you five-time award winner dory
james beard award winner dory greenspan
also the author of more than a dozen
best-selling cookbooks her latest the
just released baking with dory sweet
salty and simple not bad for a woman who
says she nearly burned the house down
trying to cook at age 12. banished from
the kitchen then it soon became her
kingdom the perfect place for us to sit
down as she shared more of her story in
between bites of her tantalizing
creations
have a gougere okay so french cheese
puff normally made with conte or gruyere
but these have gouda in them and some
cumin also dory greenspan welcomed me to
her connecticut home as she would an old
friend and when you come in you can
smell them baking and so i say hi
hand your wife thank you gujarat and i
see whatever you need dory whatever you
need
her food just part of the warmth that
envelops you the rest is all dory i got
married when i was 19 and i taught
myself to cook and bake my mother used
the oven to like
hold bread and crackers and things like
that but i found that baking
it was relaxing it was so satisfying
that you would take ingredients and you
can see things change and you bake to
share there are a million things i love
about baking as evidenced in her latest
cookbook baking with dory her 14th in a
30-year span part of a career that took
some warming up to i was terrible in a
professional kitchen why oh he's so slow
you know i i say baking is easy because
you follow a recipe but i kept changing
the recipe i got fired from my first
baking yeah for creative insubordination
that same creative insubordination led
dory to a writing job at food and wine
magazine and eventually cookbook
projects with the likes of danielle
bellude julia child and pierre ermey
they were all generous they were all
ready
to teach me
and i learned what was scary as you were
trying to build this career
i was
scared because
i was afraid i didn't know enough i was
afraid i wasn't good enough i wasn't
trained i couldn't say oh look at my
degree from cooking school
but i wanted to so i kept saying yes and
being scared
so if you would just
smoosh it around yup i'm a good
assistant
you're a good smusher she then took what
she learned and passed it on to the rest
of us one cookbook at a time i'd love to
think that the work i do encourages
people to come into the kitchen and
teaches them i think perfection is
overrated i find that
this one's skinny
and this one's a little chubbier they're
cute
when something isn't perfect in a way
you're seeing the maker's fingerprints
on it and what could be better than that
as for leaving her own mark there's her
new york times food columns
social media take a spatula and give
them a few smart smacks
it's kind of fun
14 cookbooks
yeah
five james beard awards i should be
taller i mean
seriously your list of accolades is
unbelievable
i think i was so lucky that i found
something that just
filled me
julia child said famously find something
you're passionate about and stick to it
and there was more she said we're so
lucky
i thought yeah i'm with julia this is
pretty swell she said we're so lucky
because we work in food and we'll never
stop learning
she was so curious so open to new ideas
there's always something new to learn
she was right like when dory altered her
legendary chocolate cookie recipe at a
friend's urging so
this is
a world peace cookie okay 2.0
but it looks very much like
1.0
except
i added
ingredients that i thought
matched the qualities in women that i
admire
rye flour for groundedness freeze-dried
raspberries for sass
even red chili pepper for
unpredictability when i realized that i
could
get these qualities
in a cookie that tasted
it's good delicious well you know i just
finished the whole thing so yeah
the cookies just one of the recipes from
baking with dory i was lucky enough to
devour there was also a spinach
mozzarella parmesan crumble pie ricotta
blueberry coffee cake and the lisbon
chocolate cake which earned a spot on
the cover we stopped at a cafe that
served only coffee tea and this cake i
loved it but there was no time to find
out how it was made i took a picture of
it and the following day in paris i
started making this cake just
experimenting just to try and get the
flavor that i remembered the look that i
loved dory's travels the inspiration for
many of her cookbooks including her
latest until the coronavirus hit her
inspiration then found at home with her
husband son and pregnant daughter-in-law
i had people i wanted to feed the food
in the book what i baked is because
i wanted to feed my family which now
includes her granddaughter gemma born
just a week after the cookbook was
finished
and who it's dedicated to
right now are you already thinking about
what's next i'm not always sure what's
next but i'm always
thinking of what's next somebody said to
me recently you should retire and i said
why i love what i do so much that i
can't imagine
not doing it i mean i go into the
kitchen i make something and i think
what if i changed it just a little bit
and it it all starts i can't help myself
and i don't want to
and i don't want to
so you saw me smooshing with dory i got
to bake with her which was just
unbelievable and we actually uh have
more of our conversation if you want to
catch it on our cbs morning's podcast
but i started saying i was smooshing
with her
she made me bake cookies for you
basically this is the dough that we
created together and then i baked these
remember she talked in the piece about
the prince because yeah when you're
baking at home that's what you want i
was going to mention that there's some
fingerprints there it's not as perfect
and they're still gooey and they're
delicious they are delicious there's one
of the chili peppers in it mm-hmm oh
yeah
and the raspberry in it no it tastes
right
amazing whole raspberries or
okay
you smooshed so well yeah thank you i
love baking